bonjour bienvenue dans point de vue dans
un instant vous découvrez nos invités
vous allez le voir des invités qui
aiment la confrontation d'idées mais
d'abord notre sommaire alors on
commencera par le prix de l'essence
avec cette question est-ce du matraquage
fiscal ou le prix à payer pour la
transition énergétique vous nous donner
votre avis nous parlerons aussi de cette
ténébreuse affaire khashoggi de ses
conséquences pour l'arabie saoudite et
le prince salman mais aussi pour la
turquie où le président r doan compte
bien exploiter la faire une autre
affaire que chacun compte bien exploiter
c'est celle de cette caravane de
migrants qui viennent du honduras et
veulent rentrer aux états unis
à quinze jours des élections américaines
de mi-mandat l'immigration incontrôlée
est évidemment un sujet polémique
enfin la grande guerre ces poilus et ses
maréchaux doivent-ils s'effacer pour
laisser la place à un éloge de la paix
l'elysée ne veut pas d'un centenaire du
11-novembre trop militaire alors est ce
un affront à l'armée on verra ce que
vous en pensez
bonjour denis tillinac merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes écrivain journaliste et
auteur de caractériel caractériel qui
est un récit un peu nostalgique de votre
enfance et de l'enfance difficile
attachant que vous étiez bonjour eric
naulleau on va le voir on va le voir
vous allez pas on va aussi parler de
vous alors vous êtes journaliste
polémiste animateur de plusieurs
émissions à la télévision et auteur de
quand la coupe déborde c'est paru chez
stock et s'éteint à propos du football
et des matches qui bascule soudain dans
la légende parfaitement région bonjour
alors je sais pas entre caractériel là
quand la coupe déborde je sens que
l'émission est bien parti ça va
continuer avec vous olivier duhamel
car il vous arrive c'est rare des deux
pas toujours être de très bonne humeur
mais on va voir cela
en tout cas je vous présente vous êtes
juriste fini ce politologue
je ne vais que présente et président de
la fondation nationale des sciences
politiques et pour ceux qui ne le savent
pas donc encore pas encore animateur de
médias police le samedi matin sur europe
1 et pour compléter ce plateau et son
commentaire alexis brézet directeur des
rédactions du figaro merci beaucoup à
tous les quatre on commence tout de
suite pas le prix du carburant alors en
dénonçant le matraquage fiscal du
gouvernement
ségolène royal a frappé hier fort sur
rtl depuis sa sortie le gouvernement et
les députés en marche démène pour
expliquer qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
matraquage mais d'un efforts demandés
aux français dans le combat pour
l'écologie
écoutez deux d'entre eux d'abord amélie
de montchalin députés en marche de
l'essonne puis benjamin griveaux porte
parole du gouvernement
la réalité de la transition c'est
d'aider les ménages a justement faire
évoluer leur comportement quand on a
aimé nicolas hulot eh bien on assume
d'avoir une fiscalité comportement vous
imposerez pas sur ce sujet là nous
n'avons pas l'habitude de changer nos un
fusil d'épaulé lorsqu'on s'engage dans
la transition énergétique
on le fait denis tillinac ils ont raison
finalement c'est aux français de changer
de comportement la voiture c'est fini le
tout pétrole
c'est à tout le monde y compris les
politiques
il ya d'autres il ya d'autres façons
d'inciter les français à utiliser moins
leur bagnole un consommé moins autrement
que de ce matraquage fiscal qui pénalise
évidemment les plus modestes
alors est ce que finalement comme
l'augmentation du tabac c'est pas
l'écologie c'est bien quand ça concerne
les autres mais moins bien quand ça vous
touche directement avec nous ça c'est un
principe français nous on est pour on
est tous pour le changement sauf si ça
nous affecte personnellement non c'est
une vérité prosaïque qui se déguise sous
les grands mots de transition
énergétique ou changement même de modèle
économique s'est de tout temps mais
particulièrement aujourd'hui les
gouvernements font leurs fins de mois
avec les taxes à la pompe
donc ce n'est pas très nouveau la seule
différence c'est qu'on essaye d'habiller
sa de grand bruit en effet denis la
raison sera peut-être la seule foi de
l'émission j'aurai un point d'accord
avec lui enfin c'est vrai que la mêlée
des il ya des gens qui ont pas le choix
on leur dit il faut arrêter le pétrole
il faut arrêter la bannière si vous êtes
dans la france périphérique vous n'avez
pas le choix d'autant qu'en même temps
on abandonne les services publics est de
moins en moins de deux trains pour
desservir ces zones
donc 5 peut-être que dans le cadre d'une
politique globale si si vous si vous le
faites de manière brutale il ya des gens
qui ne pourront pas s'adapter tout
simplement
ah ça oui mais on est en place une façon
pour les gens de changer de véhicule ou
la prime à la conversion
c'est déjà ça mais ça doit être une
politique beaucoup plus globale de
transport il ya des coins de france où
vraiment vous ne pouvez pas même si vous
êtes écologique à 150%
vous ne pouvez pas vous passer d'une
voiture et donc vous êtes obligés de
payer ses taxes insensé avons que ça ne
date pas seulement de macron salaire
d'airain cash machine pour le
gouvernement 39 milliards record battu
si on en revient au fait sauf erreur de
ma part parce que pour être maître chez
pas eu le temps d'aller vérifier donc
j'ai peut-être d'être contredit mais je
ne pense pas il ya augmentation de la
taxation sur le diesel pas sur l'essence
les sens c'est le prix de l'essence qui
monte pour d'autres raisons
et donc donc déjà il faut pas amalgamer
diesel essence il n'y a pas de
matraquage fiscal sur l'essence il n'y a
pas de matraquage fiscal sur le camp
même c'est pas du tout le fond du smur
en mai il ya dwyer 80 % de taxe sur
l'essence n'est pas que l'uci n'ont pas
rien a ni plus ni moins mais elle
manipule
l'essentiel du prix défense c'est des
tentations de la taxation de l'essence
reste donc la question il faut la
circonscrire sur le bief si on
s'intéresse aux femmes enceintes un spa
ou fait mais juste à cogner sur macro
c'est un autre sujet alors sur le diesel
le débat qui oppose jeunes sur le diesel
bien sûr que les deux points de vue
apparemment contradictoires sont justes
c'est à dire que bien entendu que ce
sont les gens les moins privilégiés qui
trinquent déjà c'est souvent lui qui a
acheté des voitures diesel et ensuite de
toute façon leur indépendance
achetez du disney changer de voiture
c'est exact maintenant ça fait quand
même quelques années qu'on dit qu'on va
arrêter sur le diesel qu'on va augmenter
progressivement les taxes parce que le
diesel est plus polluant que l'essence
est donc ça se défend si dire on peut
pas laisser on a eu tort de faire cette
politique d'inciter au diesel et il faut
qu'on aura par les erreurs du passé
elle est si ça va être le talon
d'achille du gouvernement c'est assez
embêtant parce que il baisse les charges
et c'est absolument vrai mais tout cet
âne il est dans l'esprit des gens par
ces augmentations de il baisse les
charges soient validées par des
augmentations de taxes parce que oui dix
ans et tous les sens c'est pas de sa
faute mais n'empêche que les gens ont
bien que l'essentiel c'est de ces des
impôts
le gaz qui est aussi fan augmenté c'est
pas de la faute parce que c'est indexé
sur le prix du lait sans doute qu'elle
même mais n'empêche que donc tout ça est
en train de de daynile et dans l'esprit
et dans le portefeuille des gens
les gains de pouvoir d'achat qui peut
avoir de de la baisse des charges donc
eh oui c'est un mauvais temps et je
crois que c'est alors pour le coup
absolument hypocrite et ségolène royal a
eu raison de le souligner de dire que
c'était de l'écologie c'est pas de
l'écologie c'est que le gouvernement ne
faisant pas d'économie parce que neil
n'arrive pas et c'est très difficile de
faire des économies mais il n'a pas fait
d'économies sur le train de vie de
l'état sur à part sur les collectivités
locales
qu'est-ce qui fait il fait comme lui on
fait tous les gouvernements vont lui il
augmente les taxes favril apercevoir
voter c'est que ça donne une impression
duplicité est à dire que l'on donne de
la main gauche il a rappelé que les gens
s'en remettra sur le coup de l'écologie
le principe d'une taxe comportementale
faut voir ce que c'est c'est on va
monter quelque chose pour que les gens
changent de comportement mais là on peut
pas changer de comportement c'est que
non seulement n'ont commencé à rendre
hommage à ségolène royal
je me suis dit ang lee sous roche non
mais attendez vous pouvez pas vous avez
tort de tessa j'ai toujours beaucoup
défendu ségolène royal qui a plein de
qualités mais enfin il est sûr qu'elle
n'arriverait pas pouvoir non mais si on
a fallu un tout autre sujet si on
revient dessus j'ai arrêté de favoriser
le diesel défavorisés le diesel ça
incite aussi
mais avant le plus à voitures diesel
comme ailleurs on l'envoie bombe par
ailleurs attendait comme ça c'était
comme ça écologique ça dépend c'est
écologique c'est pour la santé publique
parce que le design fait des particules
mais je rencontre me disent ne fait pas
de co2 si on veut lutter contre le
réchauffement
il faut favoriser le diesel si on veut
lutter contre le cancer il faut
favoriser ma mère parce que les gens au
caire mais la dhr à l'innovation
j'essaie de finir écologique est ce que
sony ségolène royal c'est bien ça dans
le dispositif fiscaux dead à la
transition énergétique pour faire des
travaux chez soi parce que c'est la même
chose sur les sanctions qui vont frapper
les gens dont on dit qu'ils ont des
passoires énergétiques les malheurs unis
peuvent rien et donc on va maintenant
les sanctionner si leurs logements ne
sont pas assez étrange de loisirs gtx et
tout ces jeunes là on est en train de
retirer pas par méchanceté pas par pas
pour taper extraits sur les pauvres gens
c'est simplement qu'il ya plus d'argent
il ya plus d'argent et je reviens un
point de départ parce que ce mouvement
ne fait pas les économies qu'il avait
promis qu'il ferait pas il se débrouille
pour passer de 80 à 95 % de vos
téléspectateurs contre moi je dirais que
en évitant les vitesses à 80 km 1 on
réduise à cette sommation alors
s'aligneront tous de ne pas être
d'accord quand l'erreur
là on peut ne pas être d'accord mais
c'est comportementale veut dire qu'on
dit vous roulerez +41 dix jours le ré 80
où on on vous force à changer votre
comportement
mais on ne peut pas forcer les gens de +
17 voitures ni à se réchauffer chez eux
je sais techniques que vous abordiez
alexis ajouté la parole de venir suite
c'est sûr testeurs de l'électrique est
ce que finalement c'est bon pas pour le
climat on avait un article fort
intéressant dans le figaro là dessus
dont on va revoir un extrait sur
lefigaro.fr la voiture électrique n'émet
aucun d'aix dioxyde de carbone en
roulant mais sa fabrication
l'e-book volant de cette voiture
thermique
ce sera pour faire il faut faire les
batteries qui généralement sont faites à
partir de métaux rares qui sont alors on
pollue en afrique et en chine
enfin les chinois pollue en afrique les
acteurs et donc du coup handicapés de
pollution chez nous mais au niveau de la
planète il ya quand même de la pollution
denis les gouvernements pas plus macron
que ses prédécesseurs manque
d'imagination il faut une transition
énergétique il faut vraiment une
révolution écologique ça veut dire une
révolution dans le mode de production de
consommation de d'aménagement du
territoire pour que les joueurs gens
soient au plus près de leur boulot et
c'est pas avec des mesurettes comme ça
que ça changera quoi que ce soit ça
exaspère les gens ça nourrit le
populisme et ça fait monter les votes
d'ex envoyer la punition et sa
sociologie fini sur les 80 alors je
voudrais rassurer olivier je roule
beaucoup sur des petites routes
corréziennes et autre personne ne le
respecte cra sociale et 80 km où il
perçoit de temps en temps vous avez
enfin les corps aujourd'hui
désolidariser la civilisation mais
puisque vous avez failli aux capteurs
des flics et roule à 75
ça fait la queue exaspère celui qui
respecte un fayot
pour voter de l'accident alors c'était
absurde
olivier duhamel nous prédisait combien
85 % d'internautes qui serait d'accord
avec l'idée que c'est du matraquage et
ben vous vous trompez olivier ses 79
mais il jouit de sa disgrâce c'est ça
c'est un terme à sa paire vers intérêts
que tu ais je prévois vos sondages ce
n'est quelques commentaires quand même
de nos internautes alors henry qui nous
dit c'est une mesure donc celle de deux
taxes et le finlande c'est une mesure
qui n'a pour objet que de continuer le
racket permanent des automobilistes sous
couvert d'une cause louable pour ses
cris c'est juste du matraquage veilleurs
69 aimerait que le gouvernement commence
par montrer le bon exemple sur les
déplacements des ministres et si je nous
dit ce n'est pas si facile dans les
campagnes donc tout ça résume un petit
peu bientôt ce sera le vélo je sais pas
si vous avez vu non taxé les vélos alors
c'est le coup de [ __ ]
eh ben vous allez vous là on entraîne
pas de carte grise pour les vélos soit
un texte qui serait pas qu'il faudrait
pas qu'ils soient volés etc
mais à la fin ça sera pour faire une
taxe parce que de toute façon il ya
besoin de les nouvelles mobilités ça va
être des nouvelles taxations vous allez
voir c'est pour la marche à pied mais
trop donc je pense que non mais je pense
que ça passe par une révolution des
transports en commun au lieu que ce soit
quelque chose pour les stores et volets
il faut commencer par la base les gens
ne prennent pas leur bagnole par plaisir
il y en a parfois mais enfin c'est une
minorité
s'ils ont un moyen de transport
alternatif crédible il le prendre on
voit là et ce n'est pas en mettant une
taxe que ça va changer comportement des
gens mais si on va passer on va proches
le site de production le bureau de celui
qui travaille c'est encore mieux mais là
ça demande plus tellement
adaptation et faudra le faire sinon ça
ira pas bien la réforme écologique alors
un tout autre sujet celui de l'arabie
saoudite alors appel perdu la face
depuis le meurtre du journaliste amal
khashoggi à istanbul c'est donc notre
sujet il y en a un en tout cas qui a
bien l'intention d'exploiter cette
affaire c'est le président turc grand
rival de l'arabie saoudite pour le
leadership dans le monde musulman
ce matin dans un discours le président r
doan assuré qu'il ne doutait pas de la
sincérité du prince ben salman
mais que faire porter le chapeau aux
seuls services de renseignement et
agents saoudiens
c'était peut-être un peu court on
l'écouté expliquer et commenter cette
opération contre cachot vie ou de la
liste en istanbul belge compte douze
zones à bis du coach nba rétine
jean a été pilonnée et jeune équipe à
robertville dit on un jour il ya un
habile pilote normand biarritz brodeur
changement beh double ainsi la bonne
partie hachée on sait qu'ils sont tous
nos nationaux et un beau diable
maastricht les olivier duhamel
il est vraiment en train de marquer des
points verdone dans cette histoire c'est
oui j'imagine une histoire c'est un an
que je ne crois pas que connaît d'autres
histoires d'une telle protestation
internationale y compris au niveau de
chefs d'état et de gouvernement pour l'
assassinat commandité d'un journaliste
par habitat teurs ceci n'a dictateurs
autrefois ça à nier amnesty
international s'est indignée la
fédération à la fin de droits de l'homme
mais le chef d'état n'était pas concerné
donc ça c'est une grande nouveauté
qui prouve que si on le met une petite
lueur d'optimisme que 1 zeste de notion
de communauté internationale existe un
petit peu et un zeste de capacité d'une
telle pression que même les états
vendeurs d'armes et autres se sentent
obligés de prendre leurs distances
c'est nouveau après évidemment une chose
qui est c'est que c'est un journaliste
c'est à dire que les centaines de
milliers de musulmans
enfermés dans des camps en chine ne
sollicite pas ne suscite pas la délation
généralisée mais évidemment si c'était
cinq cent mille journalistes je vous dis
pas eric naulleau vous avez twitté je la
mort d'un journaliste c'est finalement
plus que des milliers de morts au yémen
contre larbi ben oui je j'observe cette
indignation internationale mais ce qui
se passe au yémen c'est que l'arabie
saoudite est à la tête d'une coalition
qui mène une guerre impitoyable contre
contre une rébellion enfin la rébellion
prend le visage et les corps
malheureusement supplicié ou mort de
civils on en est à dix mille morts et on
en est à une tragédie humanitaire qui
est presque sans précédent
les gens qui sont encore sur place qui
sont très peu nombreux le dise donc je
trouve ça un peu deux poids deux mesures
après faut bien dire que non seulement
il ya un assassinat m'enfin des détails
qui nous parviennent sont tellement
effarant tellement atroce qu'en effet je
comprends que ça puisse remuer les
consciences
enfin je vais tempéré immédiatement le
l'optimisme d'olivier je crois que ça va
retomber très vite parce que le poids de
la realpolitik avec ce que représente
l'arabie saoudite avec en effet la
question du pétrole et le fait que dans
cette région elle soit un acteur majeur
on va foncer on va le on va dire
vraiment au prince est pas bien faudra
pas recommencer mais je pense que ça
retombe rapidement
on essaiera de marquer le coup mais
pardonnez moi d'être cynique je n'y
crois pas beaucoup c'est ce que les
états unis ont déjà commencé à faire en
disant bon effectivement votre version
sujette à caution mais en même temps on
va pas aller trop loin
il faut mettre un bémol sur cette
mobilisation internationale c'est parce
que c'est un journaliste c'est vrai et
puis s est restée très modérée bon on à
éviter d'envoyer des derniers
représentants du gouvernement dans
l'eure dans leurs dames lave hausse la
semaine dernière
enfin bruno le maire a dit que le
partenariat stratégique avec le
les saoudiens n'étaient pas menacés le
président trump a l'air de dire bon oui
donne nous des explications un peu plus
crédible et pillon on va s'arranger je
crois effectivement comme eric que ça
les allemands on a été vraiment marquer
le coup il ya longtemps qu'on était
lâche 0 on gueule contre l'islamisme les
âmes et l'islam les arabes
enfin on leur vend des armes avant des
systèmes de sécurité on est là quand
même
je dire on n'est pas très cohérent les
occidentaux un courageux belle et noble
alexion le rappelait autour de la table
les détaillants selon incroyable et au
risque sur cette histoire sordide eux
deux alors ça y va encore ce matin
c'était les doigts coupés en juillet
avec salman le corps enroulé dans un
tapis qui a disparu à la france parce
qu'à une question pourquoi ben salman
aurait organisé tout ça est ce que
finalement les conséquences sont là des
questions vous aurez perdu la face je
pense pas que c'est perdu la face que
perdre la face et faire preuve de
faiblesse ne peut pas dire ils ont perdu
la tête c'est à dire qu'ils étaient au
moins de l'assassinât du duc d'enghien
foucher disait c'est pire qu'un crime
c'est une faute
c'est là c'est pire qu'un crime c'est
tellement bête c'est tellement énorme
puisque dictateur qui veulent se
débarrasser et améliorations
ils passent tous une voiture on sait pas
trop ce qu'ils veulent
la faille est une telle volonté de
mettre ça en scène que les ça se
retourne contre eux sa part est d'une
stupidité absolument évident et quand je
parlais du duc d'enghien c'est
intéressant parce que l'assassinât
double en garde par napoléon va susciter
de réprobation dans toute l'europe
et finalement les la clé il ya la
communauté internationale ne va pas lui
pardonner ça ne compte pas un
journaliste
t'es à côté oui mais ce tir c'est pire
faire venir le gall enlever le nom mais
je veux dire sans procès dans la nr
dogan en comparaison passe pour être
dans le camp des droits de l'homme et à
gaza c'est donc la manière de gagner de
gamme devient gentil effectivement cessé
c'est quand même c'est sûr parce que
quand même
ben salman fait des efforts depuis son
accession au pouvoir pour me démontrer
qui veut mettre les femmes au volant
karabi sur porto les rails d'une
certaine moderne hommage des femmes au
volant et le financement du terrorisme
international franchement bon c'est
mieux que rien bah ça pèse pas très
lourd m'enfin faut faire un examen par
action générale le qatar c'est la même
chose on a tellement tolérer de la part
du qatar parce qu ils nous achètent des
tas de choses que ils ont heureusement
vous en achète aussi à paris ben oui
bien sûr quelques réactions sur le sujet
d'abord sur le côté réal politique selon
vous demandé sur twitter selon vous
l'arabie saoudite risque-t-elle de
perdre ses alliés occidentaux suite à la
sphère khashoggi vous êtes 2
près des deux tiers à répondre que non
vous ne pensez pas brownie tôt nous dit
tout le monde sait que l'arabie saoudite
est une dictature est une dictature
politique les occidentaux s'en sont
toujours accommodé et monsieur babineau
qui poursuit l'arabie saoudite investit
massivement en france comment peut-elle
s'en mêler dre qu'on écoute sur ce sujet
alexis un mot et puis j'aimerais qu'on
écoute ensuite christine ockrent qui a
une lecture aussi plus globale de la
situation ce qui peut se passer
c'est pas que j'ai une rupture entre le
commercial et l'arabie saoudite c'est
qu'on change de prince héritier le
prince héritier et baisse ben bon bah il
ya un frère ou un cousin qui va le
remplacer parce que lui on dirait
vraiment la taille gérer ça qui est en
train de se jouer et un autre à sa place
après les relations que l'arabie
saoudite
bien sûr et la question d'argent de
contrats de pétrole de tout ça il ya
aussi des questions de relations
internationales
aujourd'hui c'est un des alliés des
américains d'israël contre contre l'iran
et la turquie l'a donc partie réglé bas
donc il n'y a que des questions
d'intérêt des questions géostratégiques
dont on peut discuter à dire c'est
peut-être pas une bonne politique
mais non c'est aussi un élément du jeu
que les américains que les européens que
les français prennent en compte en tout
cas la cohérence on condamne plus
vigoureusement le meurtre d'un
journaliste que le fait qu'ils
bombardent avec des armes qu'on leur a
vendu des populations civiles à ce point
faut dire être parce qu on se mêle de
rien ils ont tous les droits parce que
avec les envoyés des chiffres qui sont
alliés d'hier
et oui je vous reviens avec cet homme
alors justement on écoute sur ce plan
s'il voulait bien ça avance ça va vous
intéresser ce que la france doit prendre
parti dans ce conflit entre chiites et
sunnites que et à l'intérieur du monde
sunnite j'aimerais que susciter qu'on va
écouter christine ockrent spécialiste du
sujet
et qui a fait un livre sur le prince
mohammed bin salman 10 mb/s l on
l'écoutait elle parle justement de cette
concurrence entre turquie et l'arabie
saoudite pour le leadership dans le
monde sunnite 1 il joue évidemment de
cette affaire pour humilier ryad qui est
son grand concurrent dans le monde
sunnite même si les turcs ne sont pas à
ramener en moins erdogan frères
musulmans sont partis frères musulmans
khashoggi étaient frères musulmans
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il se
sentait en sécurité à istanbul la
turquie protecteur ou soutiens en tous
cas du qatar que l'arabie saoudite
voulait totalement asphyxiés donc tout
cela fait des ders dogan le maître de
ballet si vous voulez pour essayé
d'extorquer le maximum de crédits aux
dépens de l'arabie saoudite vous
acquiescez il marie marque un point
c'est aussi un des éléments
d'explication de vie y compris vis à vis
de l'europe puis marque un point parce
qu'il a été humilié par l'europe et ball
américain
du coup de son but est de redevenir un
autre mot gentil avec lui pour pas qu'il
accable trop les saoudiens donc du coup
il va parce que dans ces déclarations
d'aujourd'hui il est sévère mais pas
tous sortis il n'accable pas donc ça
veut dire qu'il a gardé des munitions -
et qui va monnayer contre on ne sait
quoi aux américains et il dit juste il
faut qu'il soit jugé à istanbul la
maîtrise des dossiers
ça mange pas de pain alors on va passer
aux migrants
au du rien qui vient du honduras pour
entrer aux états unis la caravane avance
et donald trump aux abois pourrait-on
dire avec un peu de facilité à ces
milliers de migrants continuent en fait
en effet de traverser le mexique
de quoi agiter le débat politique outre
atlantique où les élections de mi-mandat
ont lieu dans quinze jours exactement et
dans chaque camp on s'accuse dans chaque
camp et républicains comme démocrates on
s'accuse de vouloir instrumentaliser la
question écouter le président américain
s'était dit hier ils étaient tous texas
[Musique]
olivier on voit effectivement pas
comment ça tu affaire ne pourrait pas
profiter à donald trump très bon là il
coupe qui pousse - le complotisme quand
même l'idée que ce sont les contre
attaques
organiser le départ du honduras l'a
quand même d'abord c'est donner une
capacité d'action aux démocrates c'est
considérable et ensuite c'est vraiment
l'essence même de la théorie complotiste
jamais élections américaines de mi tomes
ont été aussi incertaine que celle de
dans quinze jours
jamais l'intérêt pour ces élections n'a
été aussi élevée que pour celles ci
jamais l'incertitude sur le résultat n'a
été aussi grande parce qu'on assiste
avec double mobilisation et chez les
démocrates et chez les républicains
et donc on pourra répondre à votre
question que après les élections parce
que ça irait bien dans ce que vous voyez
une des raisons pour lesquelles je suis
bac + 12 ou 13 sais que j'ai le droit de
dire on ne peut pas le dire on ne sait
pas c'est une escroquerie que de
prétendre qu'on leur serve et londres
est conséquente un texte
bac + 5 donc je vais m'engager notre
connaissance du discours complotistes et
essence du discours populiste parce que
juste avant il déclarait dans cette
colonne dans cette caravane
il ya des éventuels terroristes des gens
qui aiment moyen-orient et du djihadiste
salle et paco rubio race bon voila il
émigre est économiquement du honduras
donc vraiment augagneur mal on
s'instruit écouter trump puis dit il ya
certainement des gangsters et on va on
va on va écouter l'extrait ci voulait
pas mais c'est vrai qu'il est
intéressant on écoute cet extrait où il
développe effectivement la question
toujours donald trump
m
[Musique]
technologie est interrompue le ms stress
je précise c'est un gang de criminels
très connu en amérique
non mais c'est intéressant ce qu'ils
racontent parce que moi ça m'arrive
d'aller aux états unis or il suffit
d'être depuis 24 heures aux états unis
on sait ce que donnent les salvadoriens
les gens du honduras où les mexicains
ils font tourner la baraque des états
unis font tous les boulots les
américains ne font pas vous êtes dans un
hôtel vous ne voyez que des latinos
parce que c'est eux qui font tourner la
balle
mais là ce qui est en train de jouer
trump qui joue en effet les lycées des
élections de midterm de mi mandat et il
joue aussi sa réélection parce que sa
seule chance c'est de mobiliser à fond
son électorat c'est à dire d'hystériser
des situations de dédramatiser et de
d'espérer que tout ça ça fasse 50% des
gens pour lui donc il joue très gros sur
cette affaire et c'est vraiment un
cadeau du ciel
si les démocrates sont vraiment à la
base de l'organisation de cette caravane
ils sont très bête parce qu'ils font un
cadeau énorme at rome qui me plaît je
pense que même dans ses prières après
pas une seconde mais vraiment s'il
l'avait fait ce serait oui je pense que
s'est donnée le le hondurien qui est un
peu à l'origine de tout ça est assez
proche des démocrates d'où le la ficelle
un peu grosse du du complot démocratie
jusqu'où peuvent pas tellement plus le
ce que j'ai dit c'était une figure de
rhétorique
il l'a dit mieux il a dit face en plus
vives
comment au fait que ces dépôts reste une
blague vaseuse mobilité sociale jamais
contraint martin amis vous vous êtes
trop méchant non c'est vrai à ceci près
que éventuellement ça peut aussi créer
une civilisation de l'électorat latino
oui mais tu t'es mort il est alors je
voyais ça ne m'a pas trop les nouveaux
me disais alors peut-être que c'est fait
pour les remobiliser mais là ils sont
plus de la moitié à dire qu'ils sont pas
sûrs d'aller voter
est ce que quelqu'un vu un documentaire
on va parler d'un documentaire
formidable que j'ai pas vu qu'ils
étaient faits sur 24 heures en
californie sans un seul clandestins il
avait imaginé
je n'ai plus un clandestin c'est
impossible californie et ils ont fait
une fiction c'est à l'arrêt complet du
beurre et le pays était la réalité faire
pareil avec les retraités on
s'apercevrait que la france serait
bloqué français retraités de côté dans
les travaux publics mais les immigrés en
provenance du sahel ou du maghreb et
d'accès sans doute aussi là on parle
talon d'achille tout à l'heure
l'immigration ça reste quelque chose
pour très compliqué le mur par exemple
avec le mexique je crois que pour le
moment ils sont 6 km sur deux c'est plus
ou moins abandonnée oui dieu sait que
j'ai pas envie de plaider pour le
populiste voudrait plaider pour les
meilleures façons de s'en débarrasser et
la meilleure façon sereine de prendre
conscience que dans le monde entier il
ya une hantise de l'immigration les
attentats terroristes l'an elles ont
amplifié mais elle existe elle existe et
pas seulement en europe mais je rappelle
de chefs d'état africains qui me
disaient mais vous êtes fous en france
nous on fait attention parce que nous
aussi énormément
la plupart des flux sont intel a freiné
donc là il ya une hantise internationale
c'est pas non plus la faute de 30 pour
des américains si les dirigeants
salvadorien honduriens ont mis leurs
peuples dans un état d'une odeur aussi
bien sûr ces élégants qui sont parties
des etats-unis qui ont foutu un bazar
absolue au honduras au guatemala
salvador quand l'occasion publique et la
terreur quand même windows a qui partent
et bien sûr que c'est pour cela qu'ils
participent peuvent là les etats unis
disent mais depuis deux siècles c'est
une espèce de pages blanches sur lequel
les l'imaginaire de tous les peuples les
pauvres inscrivent leurs espérances ils
continuent à venir au bien sûr qu'il a
tort et par gasquet c'est l'amérique
m'aurait pas d'accueillir ces quelques
milliers de types mais il faut
comprendre réflexe des peuples si on
veut pas qui c'est le lit que leur
exaspération dégénère
il n'a pas été élu pour ça quand même
été pour le faire le contraire de ça
donc si jamais il disait venez venez
entre elles il est mort mais avoir une
position un peu plus lumineuse mesurer
pour les raisons que vous disiez il ya
une seconde quand vous votre conclusion
dit le contraire de ce qu'il nomme de
les prémices de votre raisonnement je
dis pas qu'ils montraient pas mais qu'il
a tort non j'ai pas dit qu'il a tort il
n'a pas tort non plus quand il dit au
début on leur donne beaucoup d'argent
parce que c'est vrai que comme les
institutions internationales qui
comptent sur les américains toute la
journée l'onu l'unesco aux essais
américains car tu t'attends pas mal bon
il a il n'a pas tort quand il dit ça au
début bon il a tort comme dit l'édile
agitent la menace de deux lames stories
de moyen-orientaux plus ou moins de gea
disent qu'ils seraient là dedans sa
seule carte et sa position afin
d'orienter sa valeur à peu près psion
l'histoire des gangs et mestrez pas
impossible puisque effectivement et il
va nous on nous a quand même expliqué
pendant tout un tas de fois qu'il n'y
avait pas du tout terroriste qu'ils
passaient dans ces migrants qui après
tout on s'est rendu compte que untel
untel untel il était passé par l'accord
donc on peut pas mais le fond de sa
position c'est de dire non veut plus que
ces gens là entre mais il le dit parce
que ses électeurs lui ont demandé de il
est élu pour ça donc il va pas faire le
contraire de sa politique vient que pour
les éditeurs et vous avez donc et pour
l'économie américaine qui sait comme
l'autre aspect de fait on ne sait jamais
si bien porté c'est qu'on n'est pas si
mal a vendu ben oui mais en fait là je
dis pas que ce soit d'ailleurs
mais c'est un fait et j'ai vu aussi peu
de chômage la croissance jamais été
aussi forte
donc il a une économie qui va bien il
tient bon sur et ça tient bon en tout
cas ils affichent une fermeté sur un
élément essentiel de son programme donc
c'est vrai que pour les élections de
mid-term en dépit de sa dinguerie de 7,8
absurde et tout ça j'ai pas fait 12 ans
d'études menées avec les trois en trois
années d'études
j'y vais ça gagner dans le fait que les
sondages olivier le rappeler ont l'air
de dire que ça sera très disputée or une
mitaine traditionnellement elles perdu
par leurs parts en remplacement alors
quelques réponses et commentaires
twitter notre question donald trump
doit-il faire un geste à l'égard de la
caravane de migrants partis du honduras
c'est assez bas c'est non mais à le
titre majorité de 53%
parce qu'on appelle un geste nous dire
et nous l'eau
la caravane elle grossit même si c'est
angela merkel entrez vous êtes chez vous
bon là ça peut être bye bye ou déjà ce
qu'on peut pas reproduire parce qu'il ya
des gens qui nous regardent ici moi je
le fais c'est lui il a le droit non des
gestes qu'on ne peut pas faire parce
qu'il ya des gens qui nous regardent
mais ça peut être un geste comme ça
aussi qu'il adresse à la corée du sud et
les dessins de photos du rapport avec ce
monsieur trump ne doit pas faiblir
s'il fait ce geste ses électeurs ne lui
pardonneront pas sté crise les femmes
acceptent une caravane après ce soir à
deux puis trois brownie tôt accepter
cette caravane sur est un appel d'air et
si tu que l'onu des mondes son utilité
en mettant en place des zones de
sécurité avec soin et protection
militaires pour les civils sur les
contrastes dans la tob dans la lah dans
la série protection non parce qu'il y
avait quelques américains qu'on
entendait aussi sur les radios ce matin
qui disait il ya un ouragan qui arrive
sur le mexique et après tout s'il
pouvait aussi j'en sors assez migros a
dans les mairies de sa mesure et je vous
propose maintenant de passer un sujet
encore très différents c'est celui de
cette commémoration de la victoire de
1918 alors il fallait une polémique pour
cet armistice
une cérémonie que l'elysée ne veut pas
trop militaire at on appris ce week-end
de quoi faire réagir dans les rangs de
l'armée
c'est une insulte aux soldats de 1918 a
même commenté l'historien et ancien
colonel michel goya
on en parle tout de suite olivier
duhamel l'elysée a commis un faux pas en
disant pas trop de militaires un million
de soles d'un million 400 mille soldats
tués je ne me semble pas impossible
quand même sur la petite bête
la pub est moi je vois que non on va
parler du de la deûle à l'itinérance
mémorielle c'est ça dont vous ne voulez
nous parler
oui donc vous le coupable serait d'abord
qu'on commente non non je suis militaire
il a raison alors alexis vous des fans
rien faire
ouais moi c'est le mot itinérance
mémorielle qui me fait rigoler
l'itinérance mémorielle votre chantier
patinage patriotique maintenant produit
d'appel à najac vise les pratiques ont
décodé une itinérance mémorial enfin
silva sur des champs de bataille malgré
tout ça ça me paraît difficile de ne pas
parler des choses là il va bien falloir
un moment rendre hommage aux sacrifices
de nos soldats mais c'est bon mais je
jette dans votre sens
des moments d'absence confirmée
continuer mais aussi parce qu'il est
sorti quoi on ça me comprends pas moi je
pense qu'il est d'autant plus nominée
d'autant plus nécessaire de rendre
hommage aux poilus qu'il ya plus de
témoins le dernier poilu est mort et que
année je crois c'est el azhar quantité
ni deux voilà de mémoire pour rendre
hommage à ces hommes qui ont entièrement
disparu après est-ce que ce set
embarrassée parce que faut pas célébrer
les maréchaux dont 1 s'appelle philippe
pétain c'est un désagrément que les
allemands sont là et que l'ambivalence
de pétain et c'est partie de l'histoire
de france il ya des gens qui idolâtrent
et pétain parce que c'était le rnd
renault 14,18 et ensuite on a vu ce
qu'il est ce qu'il est devenu et il
changer leur jugement
après je pense que là c'est la
célébration de la période de paix sans
précédent que nous connaissons en europe
ne s'apprécie pleinement qu'au regard
des conflits qui nous ont opposés avec
nos voisins il faut au contraire les
rappeler pour savoir d'où on est parti
et où on est arrivé donc ce côté tour de
passe-passe entourloupe l'on nomme les
choses sans les nommer tout en les
nommant itinérance mémorial n'a vraiment
l'on comprend pas que ça soit pour ce
qui est sa porte parole cgt fo après
plusieurs conseillers en fait où c'est
un communiqué la présence ou c'est le
porte-parole qui déclare c'est duquel
une statue quelle est la phrase qui a
une statue parce que c'est quand même
pas là je vais vous le dire mais je
donne en attendant la parole à denis
tillinac pour ce côté ce que finalement
ces propos
l'école est communicant vous les
conseillez où les collaborateurs du
président macro ont l'impression que
rien n'est très clair très défini des
lignes de commenter le fait avant de le
faire non mais je pense que l'elysée
justement c'est toujours dominique
merchet de l'opinion qui a fait un
papier lundi pour dire que ce week-end
l'elysée avait dit donc c'est un
conseiller camille s'approchant du
retrait pour joueurs concernés aucun
statut
olivier et ricoh raison tous les deux
c'était plus ridicule dans cette
histoire que ces espèces de dérive
sémantique les modernes entre guillemets
itinérance mémorielle oui au lieu de
pèlerinage patriotique bon hommage c'est
une vitrine atteindre les sommets à nos
matchs s'est arrêtée in l'itinérance et
on chemine
ils sont tous ils sont tous plus jeune
que moi donc ils n'ont pas eu comme moi
un grand père invalide avis inverse nike
et qui comme simple caporal chef reçu
les la légion d'honneur donc moi je suis
très attaché au fait que l'état honore
la mémoire le sacrifice
des poilus très solennellement et
et d'une femme et d'une façon militaire
quant au canton 8 maréchaux il y en a il
y en a huit qui mérite l'hommage
rétrospective à votre reer les huit
cedip à 7,8 y compris le maréchal pétain
maréchal pétain dont le général de
gaulle dit il est mort en 1925
donc après effectivement je récuse à
100%
respectons ce pétales acquis en 17 s'est
mis d'ailleurs en plus les poilus de son
côté pour la façon dont il les appelait
mieux mieux que d'autres généreux de
votre grand père
moi j'ai un grand oncle quand ils
venaient chez nous dans le sud l'été
quand il fait du mistral
on était obligés d'aller chercher des
immenses bonbonnes parce qu'il ne
pouvait plus respirer parce qu'ils
avaient été gazées de la guerre de 14 18
est ce que je veux dire là c'est pas
pour raconter en soit cette histoire
c'est que quand vous avez vécu ça le
grand-père le grand-oncle c'est à vous
avez une transmission directe est
extraordinairement forte de ce qu'était
la guerre en l'espèce la première guerre
mondiale pour les générations d'après
d'accord c'est impossible donc votre
reer absolument d'autres façons de leur
transmettre et l'héroïsme des soldats et
l'atrocité de guerre dans l'est l'autre
et la folie et une réflexion sur les
responsables absolument pas
alexis sur le sur l'itinérance mémorial
drake ou reviennent un peu sur le
parcours vous garez vous avez rien
bataillon matin deux jours ils passent
parfois gâteau c'est pour ça qu'il
s'arrête avant pendant après je pense
que cette difficulté mais qui me semble
tout à fait surmontable et conceptuelle
à penser
l'absurdité à l'échelle européenne de
cette guerre qui était un suicide de
l'europe et l'ex-première héroïsme et
patriotisme et sursaut national
admirable du peuple français à ce moment
là les deux sont vraies à la fois et on
a l'impression que je dis pas maquereau
en particulier parce que mes dans l'est
souvent des gens qui nous gouvernent qui
veulent nous faire basculer dans le
monde d'après dans l'europe etc et dans
la paix on veut pas voir l'autre partie
mais les deux sont vraiment en est
peut-être que l'un est vrai comme les
eric naulleau cac à cause de l'autre et
ça me paraît pas extraordinairement
complexe à gérer que de dire ces gens
étaient admirables
ils ont été héroïques leur sacrifice
n'est pas absurde
même si cette regard de ce qu'est la
france
même si cette guerre au regard de ce
qu'est l'europe et quelque chose
d'absurde et un suicide
les deux sont des cibles il faut dire
les deux d'autant que nos générations
sont très très éloigné de vous interview
interrogé jeune génération même second
suivi mes études d'histoire sa première
guerre mondiale ça fait l'artiste des
moyennes à cette espèce de ski très loin
je pense que c'est l'idéal européen
c'est à dire mais maintenant c'est nous
tous on est tous en paie donc il faut
plus parler des gains quant aux rappelez
vous on avait déjà eu ça en 1916 avec le
rappeur le rappeur qui était allé c'est
une farce et un verdun pas ce qu'il
fallait pour être une chose dont vous et
courir les enfants dans les tombes parce
que c'est la jeunesse et ses courses
2016 en 2016 et sept aides et c'était
absolument du camp chirac ne veut pas
fêter austerlitz et un peu la même chose
on va pas célébrer les guerres
européennes
mais si c'est ça l'europe évidemment que
c'est ça sinon si on veut si on veut
dire que tout ce qui est passé avant n'a
pas existé
lapret n'existe pas difficile de dire
aux gens où on va sur l'orgueil
correctement vie impossible
c'est maintenant aux principes de base
pour rapporter encore une fois c'est
vrai vous avez raison la source n'est
pas identifié formellement sur un
millésime on ne dit jamais assez c'est
qu'on aurait dit à l'elysée les
combattants donc les poilus étaient pour
l'essentiel des civils que l'on avait
armé ça j'adore cette phrase
debbie voilà ces débilités de communiqué
c'était aussi des enfants qui avaient
grandi
il est mort étaient des vivants qu'elle
qui sont morts enfin bon c'est tout bac
+ 20 macro pour nous la france la
possibilité de penser le conflit
l'adversité et le national
le trader et le match ça c'est tout qui
est passé à la moulinette de la
technocratie ça c'est quand même d
invention de technocrates autour d'une
table et là je dirais plutôt que cette
hogra communiste s'était employé comme
dans le rap le crois pas malgré eux
malgré eux ils sont partis par année il
ya eu un élan patriotique c'est
indéniable qui font qu'il faut présenter
aussi dans ses contradictions seul le
côté boucherie que cat ondes hécatombe
on comptait pas les bords s'en foutait
pour reprendre 100 m de terrain ont
permis l'homme voilà non il faut
présenter ça dans toutes les dans toutes
ses composantes
enfin on peut pas mettre un chapeau
dessus en disant ça n'a jamais existé on
passe à autre chose réception et on peut
pas rendre hommage à quelque chose
uniquement en disant que c'est absurde
c'est que le nom aucune valeur dans ce
sacrifice pour lui rendre sinon il faut
plus en parler
voilà dix ans vive l'europe vive la paix
mais on sait aime le plus les fans et
guerre est une idée rigolote pour là
parce que comme on le disait les
générations qui à qui on a transmis un
récit direct ce sont les nôtres on peut
s'éteindre
comment faire après moi je pense parler
moi je pense qu'il faut absolument pas
sacrifier ces périodes
de l'histoire au profit d'autres voilà
il faut que ce soit face à ce parti de
notre mémoire ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui sa date quand même de
sentence n'est pas non plus la période
circuler ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui
dépend très très directement de ce qui
s'est passé il ya cent ans
moi je pense que les gamins ceux qui
sont à l'école gagnerait à en être
instruits je trouve une conscience de
leur billet ces fonctionnements qu'on a
tous d euros c'est que on vient de
quelques pas où c'était pas évident que
cette construction
si la lecture de 14-18 et la paix a
produit ensuite la seconde guerre
mondiale mais non il faut tout remettre
mais bien sûr il faut y compris de dire
y compris de dire un pétain était en
réalité un pur [ __ ] qui a collaboré
avec les nazis mais pourquoi est ce que
les français étaient pessimistes parce
que pour eux c'était accès à ça pour eux
c'était l'image d'un grand héroïne qui
leur a fallu du temps à comprendre que
le ballon c'était un grand héros qui a
très mal tourné et qu'il peut nous
attendons qu'il venu grâce à la peur
comme moi j'enseigne avait été à mes
étudiants que j'osais par tes limites et
un immense professeur de droit qui
prêtait la mort et réactivité et qu'il a
signé les sections spéciales qui sont
une abomination de tous les points de
vue des principes du droit voilà
quelques réponses et commentaires
toujours sur ce sujet d'abord la
question à la question qu on vous posait
sur twitter c'était donc faut-il alors
attendez comment elle était formulée
pensez vous que les poilus puisse être
un jour oublié dans l'histoire c'est
très partagés 48% en hausse de oui et
donc s'efforcer moitié mois de réserve
et s'éteindra forcément d'un temps je
pense que dans mille ans des pensions
oui mais c'est vrai que les poêles ça
intéressait sais pas
quantitatif mais le tout le centenaire
de 14 18 les chemins de la mémoire les
parcours et de sens
arnaud nous dit oui au même titre que
les soldats napoléon ils seront oubliées
hébronites au honorés les soldats morts
est un minimum
enfin monsieur babineau comme beaucoup
d'internautes no 10 cette glorification
à moi c'est l'autre versant cette
glorification de la guerre me gêne un
peu non ne s'agit pas de rendre hommage
des français qui sont cintrées
effectivement pc civils qui ont été
incorporés dans l'armée qui se sont
sacrifiés pour leur pays et s'étaient
pour leur pays pour leur patrie pour
jouer ne soit pas occupé par le par
l'ennemi c'est aussi dans cette personne
autour de cette table je mettrai à
nouveau 14 18 ans donc c'est impossible
non mais c'est assez commun en ce qui
est impossible c'est le l'extraordinaire
exploit que ça représente de puissance
d'un pouvoir politique de déclarer la
guerre et que sans couvre en fin sans
hésiter la mobiliser l'essentiel des
centaines de personnes et immédiatement
alors que avant des grands partis
prônent elle s'est imposée le refus
naguère la grève générale contre la
guerre et que le patriotisme il ya une
totale grâce au rsa pour les gens et
surtout y compris genre que tout est
aujourd'hui vous n'auriez pas sa part
quelques mieux que par quelques mutins
ces malheureux mutins qui ont été
fusillés le méritais pas compte ce qui
mériterait pour pour avoir initié une
controverse
absurde celle dont on parle et ça serait
que kim était d'être fusillé ce serait
les communicants de l'elysée donc si
tablons pas le président de la
république ainsi que par les temps qui
complétera sa durée le président de la
république je lui conseille de se
séparer de coco communiqué page mais pas
ils sont toujours toxiques mais par leur
tirant dessus quand même bon ce n'est
l'on se sent très tôt et nous allons
gagner ça venait à la place le temps que
le ballon fuse amazonie sur ce plateau
ni ailleurs nous avons tous bac + 15
minimum après ces cinquante minutes
d'émission ou encore fait les calculs en
tout cas merci beaucoup à tous les cas
la 3e demain pour un nouveau point de
vue
[Musique]